et ça lui l'avocat salue le prof
quelle tête tu fais qu'est-ce qui va pas
je sors du tribunal et ils l'ont
condamné alors que je suis absolument
certain qu'il est innocent quoi de pire
qu'un homme condamné à tort quoi de pire
comme injustice que d'être condamné pour
des faits souvent horrible que l'on n'a
pas commis oui mais ça ça n'existe que
dans les films américains et inodore
worlds ici la justice suisse ne se
trompe pas tu parles tu penses vraiment
que la justice est meilleur ici que
partout ailleurs
in other words tu pense vraiment qu'il
n'y a pas d'erreur judiciaire en suisse
mais non mesdames et messieurs je ne le
pense pas la justice est humaine
l'erreur est humaine il n'existe donc
pas de système de justice
infaillible le législateur l'a
d'ailleurs bien compris puisqu'il a
intégré dans le code de procédure même
la possibilité de remédier à une erreur
judiciaire
par l'intermédiaire de la procédure de
révision
oui mais une procédure de révision est
possible en cas de découverte d'un fait
nouveau à savoir un fait qui existait
déjà lorsque le verdict a été rendu mais
dont les juges n'avaient pas
connaissance et se fait nouveau doit
être si important qu'il doit pouvoir
motiver l'acquittement du condamné
rien alors évidemment ça va pas être
facile à trouver un
c'est pas simple certes mais c'est pas
impossible non plus il existe aux états
unis in other words un mouvement qui
s'appelle innocence project
né dans les années 90 et qui vise
précisément à lutter en faveur des
condamnés à tort pour faire en sorte
qu'ils soient libérés de prison
ce mouvement s'est considérablement
développée en plus de 25 ans il regroupe
à ce jour des dizaines d'associations
toutes membres d'un même réseau dénommé
innocence network
j'ai intérêt
c'est même passionnant j'ai été moi même
engagé là bas aux états unis en 2016
j'ai découvert ce travail formidable
fait par professeur d'université avocat
étudiant en droit et investigateur en
faveur des condamnés à tort et c'est là
bas que je me suis rendu compte qu'un
tel projet pouvait avoir tout son sens
et sa nécessité
en suisse professeur tu ne voudrais pas
créer un tel projet en suisse avec moi
in other words un projet innocence
suisse
oui projet innocence suisse
mesdames et messieurs c'est exactement
de cela que nous sommes venus vous
parler ce soir de ce projet innocence
suisse que nous avons créée à 6 en 2010
neuf ici même à genève
qu'est ce qu'une erreur judiciaire à une
erreur judiciaire c'est en fait un
jugement de condamnation définitive
c'est-à-dire il n'existe plus aucune
voie de recours
et pourtant ce jugement de condamnation
touche une personne innocente je
comprends fait l'erreur judiciaire c'est
la négation même du droit fondamental de
tout être humain ne jamais être condamné
lorsqu'il est innocent et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela que le code de
procédure prévoit que toute personne
reste présumée innocente jusqu'à ce que
la preuve du contraire soit apportée et
cette preuve du contraire elle est
toujours à portée par un tribunal
indépendant qui a kill intime conviction
que la personne qui est la façade lui
est innocent et est coupable mais alors
comment arrive-t-on à de telles
situations
quelles sont les causes d'une erreur
judiciaire allez cause d'erreurs
judiciaires sont multiples elles sont
assez semblables d'un pays à l'autre
même s'il ya quelques particularités
mais je crois la première chose qu'il
faut indiquer ici c'est que presque
jamais un système de justice fait exprès
de commettre une erreur l'erreur
judiciaire est toujours issues ou
presque toujours issue
d'une petite erreur ou débat au départ
de l' enquête qui est suivie d'une
erreur un peu plus importante et qui
finit par la condamnation d'un innocent
le grand avocat français rené floriot
écrivent ils il ya longtemps déjà qu'une
erreur judiciaire procède rarement d'une
seule et même cause voyez il ya des
causes qui sont liées à l'individu
lui-même ou prévenus qui peut parfois
avoué alors même qu'il sait qu'il n'a
rien fait mais parce que les conditions
de son interrogatoire lui sont
insupportables ou bien de l'autre côté
de la barrière
les erreurs judiciaires peuvent aussi
provenir des enquêteurs des enquêteurs
qui souffrent de biais cognitifs qui
vont les faire aller sur une seule voie
dans une seule direction
c'est ce qu'on appelle la tonne vie
jeunes à savoir lorsque les enquêteurs
ont une idée de base en tête et qu'ils
vont tout faire pour confirmer cette
hypothèse alors qu'ils font totalement
fausse route
exactement et en plus de ça vous avez
des faux témoignages qui peuvent être
volontaire ou non
vous avez des preuves scientifiques qui
parfois ne sont pas aussi fiables que ce
que l'on pourrait croire et parfois
encore vous avez des avocats qui
défendent pas très bien leurs clients
alors là j'espère que ça ne m'est jamais
arrivé j'espère aussi pourtant est en
fait obéir ben il y a le projet innocent
suisse c'est vrai nous sommes là mais
mesdames et messieurs il faut savoir que
les reins judiciaire existe en suisse
aussi un rapport scientifique l'a prouvé
paru en 2007 ce rapport recense plus de
230 cas de révision admise et ce rapport
dénonce surtout la destruction
systématique en suisse les moyens de
preuve une fois que les condamnations
devienne définitive et cette destruction
des moyens de preuve et dénoncé comme un
obstacle formidable à la reconnaissance
d'erreurs judiciaires dans notre pays
car tous condamnés définitivement ne
peut pas faire analyser les preuves
matérielles qui sont à la base de sa
condamnation
il se pourrait donc très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il existe plein
d'affaires qui s'ouvre d'erreurs
judiciaires qu on ne connaît pas encore
pour ne connaîtra peut-être jamais ouais
j'ai d'ailleurs quelques
afférentes etc sans que je puisse
affirmer évidemment avec certitude qu'il
s'agit d'erreurs judiciaires mais les
plus anciens se souviendront peut-être
de cette affaire d'empoisonnement d'un
pharmacien à la pied à la bière au
cyanure du côté de romo ou ici même à
genève
n'at-on pas condamné pour meurtre une
personne alors même qu'on n'avait jamais
trouvé deux cadavres
n'at-on pas ici à genève aussi condamner
quelqu'un pour viol sur la base d'un
témoignage reconstitué dans le cadre
d'une hypnose mais mesdames et messieurs
ça laisse songeur tout ça en fait chaque
affaire à une histoire mais certaines de
ces histoires ont des goûts un peu plus
amer que d'autres en parlant d'histoire
savez-vous ses tubes professeur que cela
fait depuis des siècles depuis bien
longtemps que des personnes luttent
comme nous contre l'erreur judiciaire
oui alors je suis un petit peu plus âgés
que toi effectivement y'a pas si
longtemps que ça encore il y avait des
politiciens des littéraires des artistes
qui prenaient position parfois en faveur
d'un condamné aujourd'hui c'est plus
tellement le cas aujourd'hui 7 h est
plutôt laissé à des juristes parfois à
des journalistes je pense alfred dreyfus
défendu par l'écrivain emile zola qui
écrivit j'accuse et qui signa même une
pétition en faveur de la révision du
procès c'est un bel exemple et ça va
être assez difficile de reprendre le
flambeau
c'est une lourde tâche certes mais en
tous les cas c'est bien ici à genève
qu'il fallait démarrer la lutte suisse
genève la ville choisie par voltaire
voltaire qui défendit et qui restera
peut-être le plus bel exemple de
combattants pour l'erreur judiciaire
dans le cadre de sa défense de jean
calas jean calas accusé à tort d'avoir
tué son propre fils et nous retenons
aujourd'hui ce voltaire ce dicton auquel
nous adhérons pleinement selon lequel il
vaut mieux sans coupable en liberté
qu'une seule personne en prison
et encore un exemple qui a gardé sous
toute son actualité en parlant
d'actualité
est-ce que tu as netflix a acheté déjà
dit que j'étais plus âgés ctoa j'ai pas
le temps pour ses bêtises et ben le
professeur serait étonné netflix et deux
documentaires qui s'appelle pour l'un
making murderer et pour l'autre wen des
six hausses ont fortement contribué à
sensibiliser la population aux risques
d'erreurs judiciaires
ah ouais c'est vrai c'est vrai ou mdsy
hausse par exemple l histoire
bouleversante des center parcs five cinq
jeunes garçons américain condamné pour
le viol d'une joggeuse qu'il ne
connaissait pas le seul majeur au moment
de l'arrestation 16 ans kyle passera
douze années en détention dans des
conditions horribles
jusqu'à ce que le vrai coupable s'auto
dénonce et cette affaire met en lumière
les causes d'erreurs judiciaires dont
nous avons parlé avant les faux aveux
les pressions subies lors de l'audition
de police le facteur qui est celui de
l'absence d'un avocat lors des
interrogatoires et le succès
considérable que connaît actuellement
aux indécis hausse démontre à quel point
l'erreur judiciaire est une
problématique qui nous concerne tous que
l'on soit juristes ou non car elle peut
toucher n'importe qui et n'importe quand
mesdames et messieurs vous vous rendez
compte que ce soir maintenant vous
pourriez être en train de croupir au
fond d'une cellule plutôt d'être assis
là à nous écouter
alors que vous n'avez rien fait mais si
mais si vous avez fait quelque chose de
mal vous étiez au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
d'ailleurs ça va se passer comment
concrètement ce projet innocence suisse
alors projet une hausse en suisse est
une association à l'ecoute de tous
condamnés qui estime que sa condamnation
est injuste qui peut être saisie par la
base d'une demande par le biais d'un
formulaire qui sera revu par le comité
fondateur de l'association trois avocats
et trois professeurs d'université dont
nous de ici présents et qui va revoir
les demandes reçues en particulier
examiner leur crédibilité et leur chance
de succès l'association donne une
priorité aux demandes qui proviennent de
personnes actuellement détenues
une fois les demandes retenues s
transmises à des étudiants encadrés par
des enseignants et par des avocats qui
porteront un regard neuf sur un dossier
pourtant déjà clos par la justice dans
le but justement de trouver ce petit
détail qui pourrait être un fait nouveau
et qui pourrait éventuellement laisser
entrevoir une procédure de révision
un tel processus est actuellement en
cours à l'université de neuchâtel et si
un fait nouveau et découvert alors la
cause la sphère est transmise à un
avocat qui représentera lui-même le
condamner devant les instances
judiciaires par le dépôt d'une demande
de révision qui nous l'espérons pourrait
aboutir à l'acquittement du condamné on
pourrait se poser la question de savoir
si en fait en faisant tout ça on se
mettra pas à dos éventuellement les
procureurs les juges
enfin le système de justice mais je ne
crois pas mesdames et messieurs je ne
crois pas parce que nous nous ne
cherchons pas à défier le système de
justice au contraire lutter contre
l'erreur judiciaire ça ne sert pas
uniquement
condamné à tort mais ça sert à l'entier
du système qui à chaque fois qu'il
condamne un innocent en fait remet en
cause en question sa crédibilité même et
ça sert même aux victimes qui
préféreront toujours savoir que c'est
bien la personne qui est véritablement à
la base de leur souffrance qui est celle
qui a été condamnée
d'ailleurs aux états unis le mouvement
innocence project a permis de retrouver
des dizaines de vrais coupables à
travers précisément la révision de
condamnations de personnes innocentes il
faut donc se réjouir de la création de
projets naissent en suisse oui même vous
mesdames et messieurs nous tous si nous
acceptons l'éventualité où la normalité
delà de l'erreur dans la justice alors
nous acceptons également implicitement
que nous pourrions nous aussi être
condamné un jour alors que nous n'avons
rien fait de répréhensible lutter contre
l'erreur judiciaire au fond c'est aussi
lutter pour la présomption d'innocence
ce principe cardinal mais la présomption
d'innocence dans tous les procès parce
qu'il est indispensable que juges
policiers procureurs même et surtout les
avocats que nous soyons bien conscient
que parfois selon un malheureux concours
de circonstances parfois tout de même
c'est un véritable innocent que nous
avons entre les mains
en fait le projet innocent suisse que tu
me proposait mes enfants c'était une
nécessité
enfin on va nous dire que nous ne
servons absolument à rien tant que nous
n'aurons pas eu notre première victoire
c'est vrai ça prendra probablement du
temps ça risque de prendre du temps des
avocats américains en particulier m'ont
dit qu'il fallait souvent plusieurs
années pour obtenir une seule révision
oui il faudra pas baisser les bras parce
que qu'est ce qu'on en a reçu des
dossiers intéressants et on peut pas les
abandonner là maintenant mesdames et
messieurs on ne peut pas rester passif
face à l'injustice
une injustice où qu'elle se produise est
une menace pour la justice partout
ailleurs disait le grand martin luther
king ou là encore une de ces une de ses
citations que les avocats tirent de
leurs manches dans leurs plaidoiries
faudra un jour que je vienne t'écouter
plaide et d'ailleurs eh bien tu pourras
venir m'écouter ça compensera mesdames
et messieurs les innombrables heures que
j'ai passées à écouter sur les bancs de
l'unité niveaux de cours du professeur
andré cools
restons sérieux tu veux bien restons
sérieux
mesdames et messieurs voulons nous
vraiment rester passifs ou alors voulons
nous regarder comment ça se passe in
other words
voulons nous vraiment ici aussi offrir
une toute petite possibilité aux
condamnés à tort de voir leur procès
réviser vous l'aurez compris notre
décision a été prise
in other words nous l'avons créé ce
projet innocence suisse excellente
soirée à toutes et à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]